وينضم الينا السفير السعودي لدى السودان
علي بن حسن بن جعفر سعاده السفير مرحبا بك
معي في هذه التغطيه على شاشه العربيه
اسالك بدايه عن الترتيبات لاجلاء
المواطنين والرعايه من السودان الى
السعوديه كيف تمت
اهلا وسهلا وكل عام وانتم طيبين
كل عام طيبين
الانقاذ لتوجيهات سيدي ومولاي خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان عبد العزيز
يحفظه الله
والسيد
صاحب السمو الملكي ولي العهد والرئيس مجلس
الوزراء ومتابعه دقيقه من سيدي صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير خالد بن سلمان
وزير الدفاع والرئيس اللجنه العليا التي
شكلت بلال المواطن السعوديين وغيرهم من
[موسيقى]
الاجانب وكذلك دقيقه من سمو وزير الخارجيه
وموظفي وزاره الخارجيه
عملنا على اخراج
كل المواطنين السعوديين وغيرهم من الرعايه
دول الخليج والاجانب الذين اتصلوا بينا
خرجنا في ثلاث مواكب من الخرطوم
الى منطقه انتقاء في شرق الليل والحمد لله
استطعنا الرغم الظروف
الانتفاليه ان تخرج هذه المواكب الثلاثه
الى
ثم بعد ذلك انطلاقنا الى
ولايه الجزيره ثم ولايه الخضاره مولايه
كسلا ثم ولايه البحر الاحمر حيث مدينه
بورسودان كل خلال مسيره الموقف الذي تتكون
من 32 سياره كان كان ترافقنا حمايات امنيه
من اولاد الولايات التي مرينا بها الى
بفضل من الله سبحانه وانا اطمن الجميع ان
هذه الاجراءات اتخذت على مستوى وكل
التي الذين تم اجناهم في صحه والحمد لله
تفضل
من امن خروجكم من هذه
من هذه الولايات هل الجيش السوداني كان
شريكا وراعيا لتامين وصولكم الى يعني
نحن كنا
نتواصل مع القدس
لتامين سلامه الموقف والحمد لله كان
في يعني تجاوب
بمطالبتنا ولم يعترضنا اي اي انسان
في ان كان عسكري او اشكال للتمويل التمويل
بالوقود كلها كانت ميسره ومسهله الى وصلنا
لذلك الامس في مدينه بورسودان وحيث كانت
السعوديه قد وصلت
عمليه الايلاد سهوله هل تم اجلاء اعضاء
السفاره بالكامل
كلهم بالكامل
خليه من السفاره يبقى في بورسودان
لبن
[موسيقى]
العديد من مواطنين الذين ابدوا رغبتهم في
الاجراء
كذلك ايضا السؤال عن طاقم الخطوط السعوديه
الذي كان موجود باستضافتكم سعاده السفير
في السودان
مع بدايه تضررت الطائره السعوديه
والسلطان بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى يخرجهم
من دائره الاشتباكات الواقعه في المطار
الى مبنى السفاره وقضوا معنا خمسه ايام في
السفاره
في امان حتى تم اغلاق مع من تم
اجناه الان وصلوا الى مدينه جده بيسوى
كلامه هل تبرر احد الطائره او احد من
المسافرين بعد هذا الاعتداء
احد من على الا
قل من
هل هناك يعني مستقبلا او خلال الايام
القادمه تامين لخروج بعض رعايه الدول يعني
مثل الرعيه الذين خرجوا معكم يعني في هذه
اليوم اليوم
ونحن من هنا تواصلنا مع الجهات التي
استطاعت تيسر موكب
خرج رعايه الاردنيين
والحمد لله خرج من منطقه
السودان منطقه الخرطوم وهم نتابعهم في
تاريخهم ان شاء الله يوصولهم الليله كذلك
الموريتانيين نفس الليبيين اخرجناهم الله
سبحانه وتعالى ثم
بتوجيهات جديده من القياده يحفظهم هل هناك
سعوديون اتفضلوا البقاء في السودان
لا يوجد
اتصل بنا عدد من السعوديين موجودين في بعض
الولايات
وهم في طريقهم الينا ان شاء الله وصولهم
اليوم
هناك اعداد مقدره لمن بقي من السعوديين في
السودان الى الان
اعداد قليله يعني في مدينه مروي في مدينه
مدني اربع اشخاص في مدينه
هذولي يعني هذه المدن يعني ليست داخله في
قرن عمليات القتاليه وبالتالي وامنا لهم
السفر
الى وصولهم ان شاء الله الليله نستقبلهم
في
ساعات السفير يعني مع اجلاء المواطنين
السعوديين الموجودين في السودان اعلنتم
بان هناك رعايه من دول اخرى يعني خرجوا من
بورت سودان الى جده في هذه السفن خمس سفن
نتحدث الان هل هناك تقديرات لاعدادهم اولا
من اي الدول وعلى اي اساس يعني تم
اختيارهم للخروج معكم
لا يوجد حقيقه احنا تواصلنا مع السفارات
والخليجيه والسفرات العربيه قبل خروجها
وبدينا لهم الرغبه في انهم يخرجوا معنا
بعضهم تجاوب معنا سريع فاغلب
الذين تجاوب معاهم السفير الفقري ورعايه
السفاره القطريه السفير العماني
قام بالاعمال الكويتي
وعدد من الجنسيات الاجنبيه عندنا من بنك
الدوليه بنك الدولي وزوجها عندنا
مسؤوله من كندا عدد نباتيه خرجوا معنا
والحمد لله الان هم في جده بالنسبه
للسفاره السعوديه هل لا زالت اعمالها
قائمه الان في الخرطوم ام علقتم العمل في
السفاره بسبب الاحداث الجارحه حاليا
طيب انتم
نقلتها الى اين نقلت اعمالها الى اين الى
بوتسودان وانت ستستمر بالعمل من بورتسودان
اكيد نعم انا سلم من زملائنا
الدبلوماسيين السعوديه بالتوفيق لكم ان
شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك
سفير وانت طيب السفير السعودي لدى السودان
علي بن حسن بن جعفر
رصدت كاميرا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج
والقس على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات